hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast precision medicine and
pharmacogenomics in community pharmacy
and primary care cell
presented by amina abu bakkar
co-president rx clinic pharmacy Avadh
institute of clinician i am g lee baca
blabbers and i will be your moderator
for today's event we're delighted to
bring you this educational web seminar
presented by Lavery's labyrinth is the
leading scientific social networking
website and producer of educational
virtual events and webinars before we
begin I would like to remind everyone
that this event is interactive we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type your questions into the
drop down box and click send well answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing in the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
ward at the bottom center of your screen
or use the ask a question box to let us
know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
amina abu back i will now turn the
presentation over to her thank you I'm
delighted to be here today and I would
like to go over the objectives of
today's presentation so the goal is for
us to identify the three approaches to
pharmacogenetic testing for patients and
describe the workflow in each model I
would like to list questions that you
could ask a partner in lab to see if
it's a good fit for your pharmacogenetic
program we look at at least five
drug-gene implications that we have seen
mostly either in primary care
studying and what resources you can use
to back up your guidelines or your
recommendations to other health care
professionals all right so the precision
medicine we are looking at it as the
future of individual medicine and it's
exciting
patients are learning about it and
they're looking for this information and
my goal is as community pharmacist
either in primary care setting or in
community setting are we ready to take
these questions from these patients and
guide them to where they could find
answers to some of their questions about
precision medicine looking back it was
President Obama's State of the Union
address and he felt like if it's the
United States a country has gone to the
moon it's time for us to look and see
how we can treat patients with precision
the drugs we designed are not for
everyone and we've always known that but
having this elegant science available
how do we bring it to the American
population and around the world the
National Institute of Health has been
conducting research since the whole
genome project and the breakthroughs of
these treatments are crucial when it
comes to individualized care but the
question has been how do we get the
population to engage so there are a lot
of questions that I face as a pharmacist
when patients that should participate in
research with the National Institute of
Health why does the government need my
DNA so these are questions that we can
do we can answer to our patients so that
way we can help the initiatives at NIH
if you look at the FDA if you go to
fda.gov lots of medications are there
with guidance and the encouragement that
these warnings about different genetic
implications are now going to pack
inserts and this list is growing every
single day as we get more information I
was fortunate to participate at a open
forum with the FDA and the question that
was being asked was what are the best
practices to deliver this information to
American public and when I was there was
an interesting panel and we had
physicians they were genetic counselors
and if you think about the role of FDA
and they want safety for the American
public
however we don't have a full
infrastructure that the entire bridge
has not been built for us to be able to
get the patient to do a test and have a
provider that's available to go over the
utility of this test before the patients
get results because we do see there's a
lot of direct to consumers and my
thoughts are how much do they know about
the power of this information because
I've had patients come to me and they
have their DNA swab they can understand
that on the ancestry part but then if
you look at the other sections they some
SIPP enzymes and it's telling a patient
they are a rapid metabolizers or and non
metabolizer of this enzyme and those
patients pass through the page and they
have no idea what it means so the only
thing I see is that pharmacists need to
step in this space and become those
healthcare professionals that can tie
the gap from a provider to a patient and
be able to counsel these patients in our
communities after the FDA I was
fortunate to be invited to the White
House Office of Science and Technology
to have these further discussions and
that's why now I do a lot of lectures
and webinars to allow other pharmacists
to enter this space so we can close the
gap and have this
science really taken up and clinical
utility singing our outcomes we cannot
go to the the background of the science
of pharmacogenomic and what it is but
the recognition is a sign of how genes
affect a person's medication response
and the thing with genomics is that it
has to take into consideration the
pharmacology on top of the genomics if
we want to get an entire precision
medicine response many people have
talked about what time which time ism is
the most appropriate so pharmacogenomics
when we were when we use the word
genomics it's more broader so it it
really takes into consideration all the
genes in the genome the determined drug
response and when we look at the
pharmacogenetics it's more narrow and
it's generally used in relation to genes
that determine the drug metabolism so
these words can be used interchangeably
the sources of variation and drug
metabolism it's not just genomics so
genomics is one piece of the puzzle but
it's very important to understand drug
drug interactions environmental factors
disease states and other factors like
age and gender that affect a patient's
drug metabolism this becomes very
important because a patient may look at
a report that says they should be a
normal responder and they should be able
to expect outcomes but failing to look
at other drugs that are on board for the
patient that could cause drug
interactions it won't be justifiable for
us to say this is all precision medicine
just because the person has the right
genomics which leads me to a term called
phenyl conversion so phenyl conversion
is a phenomenon that come
a person's genotype what would we ask
what we expect so a totally different
phenotype for example we get a report
for patient and it tells us they're in
extensive metabolizer therefore they're
normal in metabolizing this prescription
drug
however because of either a disease
state or another drug on board that can
affect how this gene would now respond
so the phenotype of the patient would
now change so phenol conversion is very
important and that's why I believe
honest have to be on board because of
the extensive drug drug interaction
knowledge so if they work with medical
providers who have the medical knowledge
and disease states we're able to come
together and help a patient in precision
medicine so drugs are currently
available as one size fits all and as a
pharmacist I have seen several patients
come on board with a particular
medication either for them or their
child and a few weeks later we are on a
different medication and we've always
known that not every medication is for
everyone but we never had a tool we
never had a tool that could justify
which patients we should avoid certain
medications looking at some of the
statistics where we're spending a
hundred and thirty six billion annually
on an adverse drug related events and
these are medications prescribed
correctly and the patient was taking
them as prescribed but the serious
effects they got and got hospitalized
where that the patients were not
appropriate candidates for these
medications
so what are the benefits to a patient
this process eliminates trial and error
prescribing and it helps them control
the cost because as a pharmacist as I
look at those patients who came in and
had the first prescription that wasn't
the right one had to have another visit
with the medical provider to get
prescribe another medication still as a
trial and error for us to make sure that
it will work they's cost associated with
it and there's the chances of potential
adverse drug events and what I also
enjoy is looking at the confidence and
peace of mind for a lot of patients who
feel like okay now that I know
psychologically that I'm taking the
right medication patient seems to have
confidence and higher rates of
compliance what are the benefits to
medical providers and pharmacists so
this provides us with a baseline
I mean medical providers are healers
when patients go to them your goal is to
help them alleviate whatever condition
that they've come in for so when we can
get a baseline for guidance it helps us
to initiate the right medications right
from the start
it saves the physicians a lot of time
with patients coming back and forth to
get optimized in a drug therapy and
again that's the whole eliminating the
trial and error prescribing and it
promotes patient adherence a lot of my
patients when they pick up medications
they'll read a lot of those side effects
that might happen to them on a package
insert so this has become interesting
when they look at oh this is the
medication I can take it has not been
really concerned about all the other
things that may happen because they have
confidence that they're starting with
the right medications and it's also
providing additional innovations for
medical practices in
in revenue potential revenue so when we
get the results this is an example of an
extensive or what we call a broad
spectrum panel and you can see depending
on the model that you use whether you
are going to be looking at entire
spectrums or a specific gene pool for a
specific disease state but this is an
example for a broad spectrum where you
have the test results and you have the
genes you have the genotype of the
patient you have the phenotype that
means how how they are showing up
whether it's a normal metabolize of poor
metabolizer and it's you see all the
alleles tested it's important to look at
that alleles tested because some results
could show a patient is normal
metabolizer but that a little tested was
not an entire pool so if a lot misses
out a particular allele it shows a core
patient that the patient is normal and
I've seen this with several patients
that had several they had two different
labs performed the test and it one and I
have the patient was normal on an
another life the patient was not normal
so that's when it told me the importance
of pharmacists or medical providers
being aware of prevalence and looking at
the alleles being tested for these
patients
so knowing that the panels can give us
all this information the question really
becomes should we get all the
information upfront or she and get a
broad panel or should we wait and see
which patients need a particular gene
panel would let's say for patients who's
going through depression do we only pull
the genes that are related to depression
and not necessarily look at everything
else that we could not upfront for the
patient which leads us to the different
approaches so I've seen approaches of
what we call pre-emptive the pre-emptive
is where an individual who may or may
not have any medications on board or any
medical conditions that they're
concerned about but as a wellness tool
to have a blueprint upfront of what
medications should they be need it would
be good for them so you can look at this
as cost saving because it's the same
swab that could give us one gene or 25
genes and also the other advantage of
looking at pre-emptive it avoids a major
delay when I need arises for example no
one's immune from depression no one's
immune from pain management because an
incident can happen in one's life and
how long would you need to get these
results back to get initiated the right
medication so that's how we look at
pre-emptive semi prented semi preemptive
is where you're selecting a high-risk
patient population and then initiating
the particular test for example if you
have a patient that has high risk of
cardiovascular events then getting
information on medications that are
related to cardiovascular could be
beneficial then we have reactive and
reactive I've seen it where once a
patient has failed several medications
now we go back to look at
let's do the DNA test and see where we
go from here so these are the different
approaches and of course they are all
justifiable based on cost because
everyone doesn't have the same
affordability can't afford the tests so
you would have to use that judgment in
your practice to see when you talk to
patients are you are they able to see
the value of all three and then make a
decision the drug metabolizes status and
this is what shows up in most reports so
you'll see a poor metabolizer this is
where two non-functional alleles
basically they have little to no enzyme
activity and these patients will be
classified as poor metabolizers then we
have intermediate metabolizers where
they have one functional allele and one
one that has decreased functionality so
there would be intermediate then
extensive metabolizers are also known as
normal metabolizers and these are
patients that have to normally function
alleles then we're going to expect
normal enzyme activity ultra-rapid
metabolizers they have one or more
alleles that have increased enzyme
activity compared to in normal or what
we call extensive metabolizers
now why is poor drug versus active drug
important so when patients are reading
these results that say you are a rapid
metabolizer
and then it tells them they need a lower
dose then they look at another drug it
says they're a rapid metabolizer and
they need a higher dose some patients
feel confused in understanding why could
the same status give them two different
results so that's why i say it's very
important for pharmacists to educate
their team members or patients about
looking at the drug itself because if
you're a poor metabolizer of a pro drug
that
means you are not activating it excuse
me so you're not activating it and
therefore you're gonna have a different
response but if you're a rapid
metabolizer of an active drug that means
you're clearing it faster so you may
need a higher dose so understanding this
becomes a fundamental clarity for our
patients because a lot of them rely on
dr. Guha
here's an example of that results so you
have waves days amitriptyline a patient
is a rapid metabolizers for curriculum
it shows that the patient has increased
sensitivity consider an alternative drug
for this patient now if you look at that
and it also says citalopram
the patient is going to have increased
response insufficient response I'm sorry
to citalopram yet they're a rapid
metabolizers so this is a clear example
of how this shows up in the results and
why it's important for patient to
understand that amitriptyline is a
prodrug in citalopram is an active drug
transporter functionality so when we
look at all the enzymes involved in drug
transport it's important to look at the
statins for the longest time we've
avoided hide those statins because they
do cause myopathy but in the world of
precision medicine understanding not not
all patients are in risk of myopathy now
we can see patients that have specific
enzyme reduced activity may be subject
for this because we have the medications
that are absorbed into target tissues
more efficiently using the transport the
transport enzymes and also they have to
be removed from these target tissues
using the transport enzyme so looking at
a patient's genetic results and looking
at those transport enzymes this would
allow us to dose statins more precisely
one of these clinical resources when I
first got into this space that's what my
medical providers needed I said yes
great amina this elegant science i'm
sure we can help our patients but how do
I evaluate this so three years ago this
was brand-new and there were not a lot
of resources out there that were that
medical providers in my community were
away off so it was my responsibility to
start searching for what are the
databases that we could find and
validate this information it's one thing
coming from a lie but it's another thing
a prescriber or a medical provider or
pharmacist validating these results for
themselves so here are some of the
resources CP guidelines and Vaughn gkb
and also there are other resources like
the Dutch pharmacogenetic working group
and the Canadian pharmacogenomic Network
but for what I have extensive experience
with is the CP guidelines they're
considered
as the gold standard for evidence-based
clinical guidelines and it comes with
different evidence level so you can see
study with the results and it will tell
you whether this is strong or moderate
which helps a lot of practitioners make
better judgment of their drug therapies
for their patients and this is a link
for fun G can be it's also an online
database
it has dosing guidelines drug labels and
it also tells you for about the
actionable gene drug results and it
shows you the genotype and phenotype
relationship so these have been great
resources and I hope you guys would find
them beneficial as well so looking at
best practice for integrating this
pharmacogenetic in our pharmacy or in
most pharmacies we consider the best fit
for it is an M TM which is the
medication therapy management because
right now pharmacists are challenged to
perform medication therapy management so
we sit down with a patient and we look
at their current medications we look at
their disease states and we help to was
the gaps in care we find patients that
are not in appropriate medications they
see multiple providers may be a star we
see duplication therapy there's
opportunities for cost effectiveness
because patients can afford their
medication so they sit down with the
pharmacist to look for alternatives
however what we are recommending is
based on if you could take it if you are
the right candidate
so in we've discovered if we could add
the component of pharmacogenomic now
we're not just making recommendations
based on one part of one piece of the
puzzle so it feels good to know that I'm
converting a patient from one medication
they cannot afford to one that they can
afford but they are also the right
candidate for it
another best practice is medical
provider relationship and pharmacists
are not there to replace the medical
providers it's more about collaborating
it's easier to coordinate care as a team
and as pharmacists are knowledgeable
with not only the drug drug interaction
omeka kinetics and now having extensive
information in pharmacogenetics and
using evidence-based guidelines they
become extenders for medical providers
because we kinetically complex patients
getting these results it's
time-consuming for the providers to go
through all the gene drug implications
and come up with appropriate therapies
but also take into consideration that
drug drug interactions before they make
all this choices so it frees up medical
providers and also technologies being
built in the pharmacies now where we can
house this information and if we're to
fill a prescription for a patient that
is not the right candidate for it and
the insurance requires prior
authorization this becomes a great tool
for the provider to send to the
insurance company or the third party
biller to show that it's not the doctor
prescribing a medication that's not on
formulary but we have results showing
that the patient is not a candidate for
what's on the formulary
and therefore getting a prior
authorization for non-formulary
medication and having this collaboration
relationship it will keep the population
safer because if we can avoid
direct-to-consumer we can introduce a
group of healthcare professionals that
are located in every 5-mile radius to an
American so far patients can have access
to a knowledgeable provider who can help
them make the right judgment and so
patients are not stopping
sustaining medications because it
appears on their result as this should
not be on it sometimes we have to have
that conversation that you have already
been adjusted for you know
yes you were time traded up and down and
now you're having outcomes because and
I've seen this firsthand when patients
and why was I put on this medication and
I could not take it but they're having
great outcomes they're not experiencing
any side effects so we had to explain to
them that we've talked to their medical
provider and none of their medical
results of their lives show that they
are at risk so at this moment they have
been adjusted to the appropriate dosage
so in order to offer this you have to
have the life lab partner and there are
many lives out there that do it the most
important thing is to look at what your
organization is looking for in terms of
infrastructure there are some health
systems that already have genetic
experts so all they need is a lab that
can process and then the genetic expert
can serve as the clinical support and
drug information but then we meet other
providers that are ready to get into
this space but they don't have that
infrastructure so in looking for for a
lab it will be important to understand
your internal needs assessment and see
if those labs could be a partner to
offer you education training clinical
support and drug reference support what
panels do they offer there are some
provide some lab partners that would
only do a specific gene pool and there
are others that would do a broad
spectrum of genes so that would be a
good question to ask and make sure the
labs are certified by appropriate
governing bodies so you can rely on
their data as well so back to performing
the medication therapy management or
what we call the personalized
medication therapy management because
now we've incorporated their genetic
information and if you look at this this
is what we've always envisioned as
medication therapy management where you
have the form of a therapy you have the
disease management whether it's
anticoagulation with ACE medication
safety patients immunization and having
this been in it's very timely with
value-based care we are now in a
value-based delivering healthcare model
so having this information I feel is
playing a huge role as we want to lower
hospitalization due to inappropriate
medications and we want outcomes for our
patients so I felt like this was very
timely so patient education material if
you're a pharmacy that is getting into
this space or a medical provider it's
good to create graphics that patients
understand because once they receive
this information and they're no longer
at your practice or they travel
somewhere else they still have that
visual of understanding the value or
what we call the utility of the test so
there's many ways this is just an
example how you would create patient
education material and have them
understand what they're purchasing but
following the test has been very simple
mostly in community pharmacy we've seen
the cheek swab approach so it's a cheek
swab on each side and then the results
are sent back to the lab and it's been
an average of three to five days to get
the results to come back then you get
the results and now you set an
appointment to go over the reviews so
again it's important for the patient
education component sometimes patient
feel that now that they have this
results they should be able they
shouldn't experience any side effects so
that's where a pharmacist is
valuable because and I tell a lot of my
patients no we expect you to get the
right outcomes for example if you took a
prescription medication that is supposed
to make you drowsy it will make you
drowsy so if they considered drowsy as a
side effect then they want to take a
medication that is on their appropriate
genetic outcomes however they don't want
to be drowsy so this is it's a very
important time when you sit down to do
these reviews and it's also important to
go through the disclaimers about the
test that pharmacogenetic versus
precision medicine so pharmacogenetic is
where yes this is your gene results and
this is what it says you can expect
however let's look at your renal
clearance let's look at other
medications being on board let's look at
your allergies so there a lot more
things to call it completely precision
medicine and always include the medical
provider because they have the full
picture of the patient I say it's the
best practice patients can approach you
in your pharmacy and say I would like to
have this test done but really to have
results back and their medical provider
who sees them for their care is not
aware that these patients are doing this
test could really compromise the patient
provider relationship so we've always
found it a way to call the provider and
let them know that the patient's
interested in this and will it be okay
for us once we get the results to share
with them because if you have findings
you're not their direct medical provider
you cannot initiate we cannot just
adjust medications so the collaboration
is key and I do let the patients know
that so in the checklist you go through
confirm their current medications and
also as we talked about counsel on
anything else that a pharmacist is able
to talk about their preventive care
counseling and looking at the evidence
level to make sure the results that are
being acted upon of those that have
actionable data and coordination of care
with their providers also try
understand the limits of the reports
that you have what does the lot deal
with medications not covered on the
testing panel because when a patient
fills out a form they fill out all the
medications and then they're expecting
to get results of each one of the
medication so how does the lab address
those medications like hormones or other
medications that they do not cover so do
they just say the patient's okay really
or do they specify that these these
medications do not go through the
genetic pathway does the lab consider
the different dosage forms do they look
at oral parenteral topical how does the
translation software interpret the
guidelines you know so when they're
giving results what are they putting in
terms of what's actionable you know
where are they getting their data from
and also we found some of the limiting
factors of their translational software
that don't take into account all the
pharmacogenetic data and we found this
there was lack of pharmacogenetic data
for ultra-rapid metabolizers for Rebecca
resolve so it's good to look at the
limitation and compared with other PP
eyes as far the proton pump inhibitors
just to see what metabolic data shows up
on those potions of drugs most results
come as a red yellow and green
but again as health care professionals
we want to make sure to encode past
everything of precision medicine and
Green doesn't necessarily mean go we do
have to look at other aspects of the
patient and other medications so let's
look real quick about examples of
disease states that seem to have had an
impact in community settings one is pain
management no one's immune from pain the
United States we have a huge opiate
epidemic so pain management is key in
helping patients know the right
medications right from the start
their manager genetic contribute
to opiate therapy and I'll go through
626 is the most important enzyme to look
at when we look at coding the co diem
goes through a pathway and without the
conversion of C to D six pathway
patients are only getting the untested
effects of codeine in order for them to
get analgesia it has to go through the C
to D six pathways which gets converted
to Morphin and that's what gives them
the analgesia otherwise patients are
only getting the untie toxic effects
we've seen a lot of case report and this
is where it becomes so important for
example these black box warning for
codeine right now in children however
understanding this genetic
pharmacogenomics codeine is a great drug
if we give it to the to the right
patient so it's not like that I don't
believe it's a full ban because if I
look at this together there's a few case
reports you have a two year old boy that
had was discharged after I mean getting
their tonsils removed and there was sent
home with codeine and Tylenol they died
on the third day for surgery but when
they did get the cause of death patient
was ultra-rapid metabolizer of c2 t6 and
the KU Dean level was zero point seven
milligrams per deciliter
but the morphine was 32 nanograms per ml
so that two-year-old boy received
morphine and lethal doses so it's not
that the codeine was bad but the patient
themselves were ultra-rapid metabolizer
c26 so they just converted it on to
Morphin same to the four-year-old boy
that was discharged after an overnight
stay and was sent home with liquid
coating and they had morphine toxicity
same to a full-term infant that died 13
days later because the mother was all
terrific
wiser that was given tylenol number
three which is when you look at the
categories of breastfeeding it's
appropriate for the mother but what the
mother passed into them to the milk
because they were a rapid mint
metabolizer was morphine so the baby
received morphine so looking at this
case reports just tells us the
significance of really embracing
pharmacogenomic and making clinical
utilities out of it so we can prevent
unnecessary deaths like this so if you
look at see peak recommendations there
for the sake of time I just wanted to
show that it does classify for the ultra
rapid normal poor metabolizer what they
would consider as alternative the
prevalence African or Ethiopians have a
higher ultra rapid phenotype and this
tells me in the future it wouldn't
matter where what race people are that
we normally stratify the risk factor we
would need to know the specific genetic
pool so we are able to treat them
accordingly despite of a geographic area
and if you look at the different races
here from occasion to Asians you'll see
the prevalence of poor metabolizers so
you have patients that receive pain
medications but they come back to the
pharmacy and say this doesn't work for
me and unfortunately there's a stigma
around opiate abuse so you have these
patients being categorized as some of
their drug seekers but if we had their
genetic information they are probably
poor metabolizers and so they are not
converting they're not going through the
ct-6 pathway to get analgesia another
category is cardiology and when we look
at cardiology it's a high risk disease
state because it causes from stroke to
death and when you look at this
clopidogrel and warfarin are the top
drugs that we really look into
especially for patients
are either undergoing if they've already
had a stroke before or they're receiving
a pacemaker you know so they've had
bypass surgery and now we want to
prevent cardiovascular events so these
patients if we do not get the right
information they are going to get an
event and they will be back in the
hospital or even cause death
so the Centers of the CMS has this
cardiac bundle payment and this is all
coming back to value-based medicine
Macra is the law that does that and so
it's supporting new payment and
incentives for hospitals to reduce
readmission so this is very important
this is a very useful for hospitals that
have cardiac units it will be beneficial
for them to make sure they have the C 2
C 19 is the enzyme really involved in
the clopidogrel to make sure patients
being prescribed that are appropriate
because they had they did a study and
that poor metabolizers and intermediate
metabolizers for 2 C 2 C 19 were
readmitted for a thrombotic event within
60 days of initiation so this is a very
appropriate to our test and even if this
cardiologists are only interested in CTC
19 this could really meet the incentives
of readmission reduced readmission with
patients that are intermediate or poor
metabolizers again the CP guidelines
would classify the patients and would
give alternatives antiplatelet therapy
and these are the prevalence you can see
Caucasians 40% ultra-rapid if your ultra
rapid metabolizers C 2 C 19 because
clopidogrel is an act is a prodrug
that means you're converting it to the
active form at fast and you're at risk
for bleeding and then if you are non
metabolized
then if we are poor metabolizer then
you're not converting it at all so you
have higher chances of having those
events because you don't really have an
active drunk on board warfarin is key
because there are two components to be
looked at so it's C 2 C 9 and the core C
1 so when you're looking at warfarin
both these genes have to be looked at
together
in order to come up with dosing guidance
and FDA has the recommended daily
warfarin dose based on the the course T
1 and the patient's c 2 c 9 genetic
results and here's an example beta
blockers beta blockers are again back
into cardiology the enzyme involved
we're looking at is C 2 D 6 and the most
important thing is patients who have
extended beta blockade because of being
exposed to metoprolol so looking at
which medications for patients that are
gonna have the variant and that the most
important variant in this 66 is the star
for allele so in the absence of this
activity patients have had a higher
exposure to metoprolol and they have had
a decreased heart rate that have taken
back into the hospital
so alternatives for this would be the
American the beta blockers that do not
require the C 2 D 6 pathway and that's
like the bisoprolol atenolol caretta law
and these are some of the guidelines
when it comes to the C 2 D 6 and
metoprolol dependent use demonio 'kathy
I had referenced it earlier where
patients may have myopathy but now we
know that it's not every patient that
had gets myopathy it's
patience with reduced activity for SLO
c1b one gene that's the transporter that
gets the statins out of the muscle
tissues so they don't have a functioning
SL c or one b1 then they are more likely
to express rhabdomyolysis and here is a
chart from the cpt guidelines that would
allow you to dose patients based on the
results neurology we look at
carbamazepine as a drug at this moment
patients with Asian ancestry they have
high prevalence of a positive HLA B and
this really exposes them to a Steven
Johnson syndrome so if you are in a high
population of Asian descent this will be
a medications whether it's being treated
for epilepsy treatments that if this is
a drug of choice this patients would
highly benefit for being screened for
the HLA B and these are strong evidence
from the cipa guidelines when it comes
to problem SFM antidepressants
antidepressants are huge because
patients this is what I've seen the most
where patients are different medications
before we can get it right already we
knew we needed six weeks for us to get
results but now imagine six weeks on a
wrong medication and then you have to
get another one and we wait six weeks
and these are patients that really need
immediate relief because we've always
heard or warnings that antidepressants
be careful they could cause suicide so
my question is is the antidepressant
causing suicide or are we giving
that are depressed medications that they
can are not the right medications for
them so technically they're not taking
anything and then they commit suicide so
that's something too I've always thought
about in the community setting is now
that we have this information I believe
this is one huge disease state that we
could at least make sure the patients
are on the right medications
antipsychotics and ADHD and when and
I'll just go back the enzymes that we're
looking for an antidepressant is the
students you see 19 and some of the C to
D six as well when we get to the
medications that are with the
antipsychotics so on tyson colleagues
ADHD they go in HD ADHD medications are
very similar in using the 6 to t6
pathways so looking at each medication
and making sure that the patients are on
appropriate medication so when I I work
a lot with parents with ADHD children
and this is a painful point for them
where the medication is either too much
and the child is just zoned out
completely or they get calls back from
the school where there's a lot of
hyperactivity and then the cost
associated with taking time away from
home from work taking the child back to
the doctor getting on the different
medication and not having expected
results so we found this to be extremely
beneficial for those patients any
questions thank you so much for your
time hope you've enjoyed it and I
encourage any questions right now thank
you and Mina for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop down box located on the far left of
you
type your question into the box that
appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for let's get started
our first question it does insurance for
this test
great question so when this first came
into the market the insurance were
paying for it and then slowly after that
because they were paying for broad
spectrum and if you look on the
insurance point of view is that they may
not have seen immediate ROI because this
is mostly a preventative tool so with
that in mind they've now come for a
narrow group of patients that they would
pay for patients who failed some
antidepressants patients who fail some
pain medications and also patients who
are undergoing car do anything with
cardiology they would pay for so it's
more specific our disease state or what
we say specific diagnosis that they
would pay for but it's coming back in
the market as more research is coming in
and more data is available for them to
justify their ROI great and our second
question says what a patient needs to be
swapped again if a new drug comes in the
market so depending on invisible
relation these are questions that you
would ask the lab whether they store the
information so we unless our new pathway
comes but if it's any of the existing
pathway the new drug will just go the
same way so if let's say a new drug
named ABC comes to the market but it
goes through the CDC's pathway then we
already know that information the
patient doesn't need to be swung because
we already know they are either an
extensive or a non metabolizer or a poor
metabolizer c-26 so that can be added on
their panel but if a new pathway comes
and it's a totally different gene that
needs to be tested then the patient
would need a new swamp otherwise I'm not
sure if any pathway any new pathway has
come to market in the last I don't know
how many years thank you
your time for one more question and this
one says how do you store this
information to be used every time a
patient is prescribed a medication or
receives a medication in the pharmacy so
in primary care especially now we have a
lot of the electronic medical records
that are building in what we call the
clinical support where you can upload
all these tests in and once the patient
has received it before prescribing it
helps with the clinical decision making
for their providers so in the pharmacy
side this technology is being built in
as well right now for patients that
we've received tests have been placed in
as the medications they cannot take
completely as if they're allergic to and
a level of and these will be like level
highest level patients that could be
intermediate metabolizers and we just
need to kind of be alerted and want to
counsel the patient in the provider will
put it in a category that it's still an
allergy but it's something we can
override and that's what we've used so
far but a lot of the dispensing
software's are expanding their abilities
to be able to house this information and
every time a new prescription comes in
it would alert the pharmacist just like
it would alert any other drug during
interactions so yes I'm excited that the
technology is stepping up as well so
from clinical decision support in the
EHR to housing this information for
patients in their dispensing is sure
going to improve how we prescribe and
safer
patients I would like to once again
thank Amina Abubakar for her
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be a bit
look for on-demand viewing through
August 2018 you'll receive an email from
lab rats
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed an HIV bit that's
all for now thank you for joining us
we hope to see you again goodbye thank
you